[Music]
shannon has a question for us
what is the number one thing
professional organizers recommend to
prevent unnecessary items from coming
into my house in the first place good
question i'm on the edge of my seat
or julia's answer you talked about this
briefly with the paper clutter there a
moment ago
one thing that i do is i have an app
called paper karma this is not an ad not
sponsored i don't know these people but
it's helped me eliminate a lot of the
junk mail that comes into my house
because it unsubscribes you from all of
these different junk mail lists and so
paper karma has eliminated probably 90
of the junk mail which let's face it the
post office is now just a junk mail
distribution service it's unbelievable i
very rarely get something in the mail
where i'm like yay
right
and yet every day i'm bombarded with
someone else's burden someone else's
clutter and so is there a
professional organizer solution
for non-paper clutter
yeah so for me i always like talking
about my own
experience with clutter and what has
helped me personally so i don't know
what all professional organizers will
say however for me when i really
decided to eliminate debt get on a plan
with my husband i'm a big fan of dave
ramsey and and we use the every dollar
free app which i also not you know get
nothing for saying that when i started
logging every purchase that i made and
when our family started doing that what
came into the home really started
changing like everything in my life
changed when we had to do that when i
tell people that i did that some of them
look at me like you are crazy i could
never do this or i can't even imagine
sharing this information with my spouse
i'm like how can you not be sharing this
information i didn't do that for years
though and i was just buying buying
buying getting nowhere so for me that is
what has helped me incredibly and i
often share that story with other people
is that it prevents a lot of stuff
coming in because i am physically
logging it i have the free version where
you have to log it it doesn't auto go
from the bank account which makes me
even more mindful of everything i
purchase so before i click the like
instant buy on amazon i'm like oh my
gosh i'm going to have to be putting
this into every dollar do i did i budget
for this do i really want to do this
right now
that has helped me so much so that's
usually what i share with people is that
mindfulness about purchasing and also
just like having that plan in your
family yeah no i use the every dollar
app as well and i totally agree like
there are some times where i won't buy
something because i don't want to have
to take out my phone open up the app put
it in yeah there's a little resistance
there yeah yeah i thought about getting
the free version too it's funny you say
that because i'm like i don't want it to
be automated like i want the pain of
having to manually do this
you want to add that little bit of
friction
because there's this common
misconception i'm going to remove all
the friction from my life i want my life
to be
seamless and easy all the time when you
remove all the friction
what you do is you lose traction it's
like
to remove friction on the road you just
put ice all over the road black ice and
you're sliding all over the place from
guard rail to guard rail you're going to
crash without any traction at all and so
what you're talking about is adding a
little bit of friction that gives you
the traction you need to avoid bringing
those excess things into your home yeah
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free